avant d'arriver dans le haut doubs
regina a fait un bref séjour dans un
autre établissement de savoie elle se
souvient y avoir vécu dix jours dix
jours de calvaire
et si vous a choqué la façon dont les
aides soignantes
mais c'était pas des aides soignantes
c'était des dates de service si vous
voulez alors elle maltraités
physiquement vraiment des dépenses
quotidiennes arrivé ici il ya un an elle
s'estime chanceuse dans cet ehpad regina
se sent bien et ne s'ennuie pas mais
elle reste lucide sur la situation du
personnel soignant le temps de venir
vous voir
bah pas beaucoup pas beaucoup parce
qu'elles sont pas nombreuses et puis ya
quand même beaucoup de travail à faire
moi je vous l'affirmé à cette heure les
choix à faire qu'après le plus personnel
et awa pour le des médicaments en bd le
médiéviste fort à l'ehpad du larmont on
compte 180 équivalents temps plein pour
252 résidents par service et par jour
une seule infirmière et six aides
soignantes prennent en charge 47
personnes
insuffisant selon myriam cette
infirmière doit parfois renoncer à
certains soins faute de temps les
personnes qui sont trop difficiles à
mobiliser du fait du fait de leur
handicap
s'il y manque une ou deux agents on peut
pas les
il devait par exemple c'est trop c'est
trop la vrs tony elle qui voudrait en
faire plus et faire mieux doit souvent
se résoudre aux soins de base
cette souffrance morale s'ajoute avec le
temps à la souffrance physique mes
collègues surtout aide soignante pas
c'est un oui à partir de 40 ans elles
ont toutes des preuves circulaire niveau
tendinite garantir un ratio d'un
soignant pour un résident alors qu'il
est aujourd'hui de 0,6 revaloriser les
salaires
assurer un financement pérenne de l'aide
à l'autonomie les revendications sont
nombreuses et le chantier est vaste le
gouvernement en prendra-t-il la mesure